everybody
Welcome to the April Meetup
and I am very excited about this one we
all know this is the open statistical
programming Meetup it's not just R it's
R and friends we have R we have python
SQL Stan Julia and JavaScript today
so we're doing a lot we've had C plus
plus we do any language that's open and
statistical base so we're very happy
that this JavaScript language you know
javascript's very big
um we've been very big favor but very
big in the data world lately not just
with python script and web R but just
generally all the things you can do with
HTML widgets and JavaScript so we're
very excited to have this talk but first
things first before we do anything we
start every Meetup by seeing who is
hiring
since we're not in person you obviously
can't stand up and say anything in fact
um Allison and I are the only two people
on screen right now so if you are hiring
go to the NY hack our slack and
publisher hiring we can get to the my
hack our slack I'll post this in the
chat the link to the slack so everyone
here can go join it and post a job so
you're looking to hire somebody go to
the link I just sent you join our slack
go to the job the job postings or jobs
posting search for jobs and you'll see
the channel there you can put your job
up there I always looking to get people
hired here
so after you've gone and posted a job
let us know where you got your pizza
from
mine is from Papo those of you in the
city know that there's Tapo veso posto
Grupo A few others uh we got our some
taffo and you see you know you see the
nice charring on the back and it looks
like it was in a gas deck oven there's
some perforation there when they rolled
out the dough good cheese locks but
sitting at home for you know about 10
minutes but the cheese lock is there so
I'm very excited so folks let us know
where you got your pizza or other food
from if it's other food let us know what
it is if it's Pizza tell us where it's
from we're always very excited to share
this video
so that's our pizza for this week for
this month
um
next month we are very excited we'll be
back both in person and virtual the
exact announcement will go out tomorrow
but the may meet up will be on May 9th
in person and virtual and it will
feature Jeff Ryan
those of you who don't know he is the
person behind the original creator of
XTS for time series objects and Quant
mod for pooling financial data and the
ever so active base R user we are very
excited to have him the announcement
will go out tomorrow of all the details
if you want if you're in the city or
near the city and want to attend in
person great if you're virtual attend
virtually we're going to do it both
we're very excited for this Meetup again
that's May 9th Jeff Ryan gonna be very
exciting days
also other upcoming both in person and
oh actually before you get to those
we have speakers lined up for June and
July but we don't have space so if you
have office space or event space or
theater space or any kind of space in
New York and you'd like to host the
Meetup be in touch you can find me on
Twitter you can find me at
gerrylander.com you can find me on
Meetup you can find me on LinkedIn you
can find me atlantaal linux.com you can
find me in so many places find me and
let me know you have space uh we're
really interested in doing more and more
of these both in person and virtual but
we need space before the pandemic we had
tons of companies always had office
space available of various sizes we'd
love to get back into that so let me
know if you have space because we are
looking both for June and July and just
the rest of the year in general anytime
we have space available we will host it
in person and virtual so let me know
other upcoming events that we do have
space for already is the New York R
conference we did like the first big
blast the other day uh it is July 11th
through 14th both in person here in New
York City same theater as last time the
French Institute and virtual on the
virtual platform uh 11 through 14th the
first two days of workshops by like Rob
Hyman and Max and a whole bunch of
other workshops then the next two days
are two days of conferences those of you
that have attended you know what they're
like 20 minute talks no questions every
three speakers at most there's a break
sometimes after two speakers lots of
food there's Breakfast there's lunch
there's snacks there's drinks there's
music and just really good educational
opportunity
if you want to learn more I'm going to
paste the URL in the chat
and if you use code NY hack R part of my
loud keyboard use code NY hack R you'll
get 20 off tickets
uh we're very excited I think this is
like this is the now the Ninth Annual I
have to do the math might be eighth
annual I'll check
um we've been doing this for a while
we're very excited to be back in person
again for our second year in a row and
virtual so we have both really excited
another one of our conference in fact
I'm wearing the nyr shirt that's how
excited I am now I own a lot of these
shirts so I wear these almost every day
in different shades I have all the
different colors but you know I'm really
excited nonetheless
and it's for the Rangers tonight let's
go rangers right
so October 18th or 20th is our R in
government and public sector conference
in Washington DC at Georgetown
so October 18th through 20th the first
days is Workshops the next two days are
conferences similar format is in myr 20
minute talks but there is obviously a
government and public sector theme and
that's government at the local state
County Federal International levels we
have people from other governments
around the world it's public sector like
education and nonprofits again for that
you can go to this URL which is very
similar to the myr your your url you'll
notice it's rstats.ai gov very similar
also the discount code and my hack car
NY hackr gets you 20 off tickets we are
very excited about that it's going to
officially go live tomorrow I believe
if you're looking to speak at the Meetup
or one of the conferences send me a
message easy way to get in touch right
send me a message we're always looking
for speakers for above the conference
and the Meetup
and we have one more conference we're
helping put on down in Tampa in August I
forgot the dates I didn't write it down
that's what I'm saying don't write it
down but you can go to d4con.io to learn
more about that and again if you go to
that website you want to buy tickets use
code NY hackr for 20 off so lots of
discount opportunities
um if you're looking to speak or sponsor
be in touch
lastly if you want to learn more about
our previous talks for the Meetup go to
nyhacker.org just like the discount code
notice the theme here go to that and we
will um there's videos up there there's
slide shows there's listing of events
lots of good stuff
then really one more lastly for
questions since we can't all just stand
up and raise our hand because we're in
this virtual box here if you have a
question
put it in Slack please don't put it in
Zoom I can't copy and paste from the
zoom chat I've never been able to I've
been trying for years now I can't copy
and paste and I need to keep these notes
written down somewhere so please go to
slack I'll put up the email address for
slack one more time
go there and there is a channel called
monthly Meetup chat
go there ask the question there I will
collate the questions at the end of the
talk I will ask them life will be a lot
easier for everybody if you do it in the
slack not in Zoom please thank you all
right with that I am very excited for
this JavaScript talk
um potting a JavaScript is so hot right
now and we have an excellent speaker and
you may know her from her car cartoons
are the wrong words drawings
cartoon history great I don't think
cartoons is a bad word yeah drawings
cartoons yeah whatever you want to call
them if you've seen any tidy verse style
drawing Lily it was most likely made by
her and not just lately we're talking
for years now they're really awesome
every time I see them I love seeing
these things
um she does a lot of other cool stuff
Beyond these drawings but they're
freaking awesome so go check them out
look up her drawings and she's going to
give us a talk today about plotting in
JavaScript uh using a grammar is it a
grammar of Graphics is what we're gonna
say it using grammar Graphics which a
lot of you are probably familiar with so
everyone please welcome an emoji welcome
to Allison
awesome thank you so much so while I'm
sharing my screen I'll just say thanks a
bunch for the invitation to join you I
did not get the pizza memo uh so now I'm
jealous of it sounds like multiple folks
who are are eating pizza during this
session but try to grab some after
um so yeah uh I'm really excited to be
here today I'm Allison hello long time R
user teacher artist
um fan and I'm really excited to
introduce a new tool that I think is a
really nice entryway to get into
JavaScript data visualization and that's
a library called observable plot
um so I'm gonna do I'm gonna walk
through some slides but I'm gonna try to
get through the slides quickly because
what I really want to get to is some uh
interactive coding that we can all do
together
um and you'll be you can if you want you
can either watch as I code or you'll see
that you'll be able to write a
JavaScript code right along with me in a
little notebook that we'll be playing
with
so I'll start with some slides and and
I'm planning on these only being maybe
10 minutes or so
um but first if you're not familiar if
you've been working in r or other
languages and aren't familiar with
JavaScript JavaScript is an object
oriented programming language and that
oftentimes is described as the language
that like brings the web to life uh so
if HTML is kind of the bones and CSS
adds some styling JavaScript is the way
that we can make things interactive or
animated
um but you can also like just work it's
a it is a complete programming language
you can do your analysis and modeling
and data wrangling all in JavaScript too
but this is kind of how it's most
commonly known
um and if you've been working in our
python to do data visualization
especially interactive data
visualization you might have already
actually been using JavaScript under the
hood so if you've used packages like
plotly or High charter or giraffe and I
love giraffe just a little shout out to
draft they're all wonderful but um
giraffe I I really really adore
um our HTML widgets a lot of these under
the hood
um are wrapping JavaScript code to make
interactive plots and so that's awesome
and if that is all that you need then I
think that's great but at some point
like I think this this tweet from Tanya
Shapiro who's an amazing
um data visualization expert says it you
might find yourself like the more you're
trying to create interactive
visualizations for the web the more you
might just want to like create it in
JavaScript like in the in the language
of the web
um as you want to create things that are
more customized or or actually see the
actual code that's creating it so at
some point you might find that it comes
back to JavaScript uh but that's all
right because JavaScript turns out is a
a really fun language to learn
another another reason you might have
been thinking or hearing about
JavaScript and in particular observable
which is the company that I work for is
that Porto
um enables you to also add JavaScript in
in cells in code chunks in quarto
documents so you're actually able to
include JavaScript code like all the
code that I'll write today that we're
working in an observable notebook you
might see this showing up as OJs sells
within your quarto documents so you
could add it there too and then once you
render it then you would be able to see
the outputs of those cells too
so in particular we're gonna be um
learning a bit about one particular
Library we're also going to learn a few
JavaScript Basics that I think are like
in my like top five wish I had known
when I started so we'll learn some basic
programming just through our examples
but we're going to be focusing on this
Library called observable plot which is
a JavaScript library for fast and fully
customizable web ready data
visualizations and it's from the team
that created D3
um and as a comparison in data
visualization D3 is this really popular
and widely used framework for creating
highly customized data visualizations
but it also means that even to create
kind of standard chart types you're
often building every single piece from
scratch so you can it has the the
flexibility of truly like manufacturing
and customizing every single detail of a
chart but that also comes with it maybe
50 lines of code to make a relatively
standard bar chart because you're really
building it piece by piece
um plot is built on D3 by the team that
made D3 which means it also plays nicely
with D3 it can be extended with D3 but
there is an added layer of abstraction
in plot that uh means that you get to
start with code that's a little bit
closer to some of these like standard
charts that you might want to create
which means that you can get up and
running
quite a bit faster than maybe you would
with D3 but it's also a great entryway
to learning D3 and at the same time it's
in JavaScript which means that it's uh
still expressive and fully customizable
but can provide this nice entryway that
then you could continue building on and
add D3 for animations and transitions
Etc
so we're going to be starting with
observable plot today
um and hopefully for those of you where
you've already been working in ggplot I
hope that this quote from Mike Bostock
creator of D3 and observable plot shares
which is that plot employs a layered
grammar of Graphics inspired by Vega
Lite ggplot2 Wilkinson's grammar
graphics and Burton's in simology of
Graphics
um so the plot we don't refer to a
specific chart type instead we build
charts layer by layer using marks scales
and transforms so this hopefully is like
when you see these comparisons I'm going
to show next between
between GD plot code and observable plot
code you see like how closely they align
um which just like just to say if you
are already working in ggplot that means
you've been building your like
understanding and practice of using the
grammar of Graphics to build charts and
that Maps like directly on to how we're
going to create charts in observable
plot so you're actually already like a
lot of the way there
so you know a lot if you you know a lot
about observable plot if you've been
building charts in ggplot
so I wanted to show just before we hop
into a couple of examples which is going
to be the bulk of the time that I spend
today
um is a minimal minimal minimum minimum
viable comparison between Gigi plot
coach and on the left here and
observable plot code shown on the right
here now it can be a little bit when you
first start JavaScript I remember
feeling like what I'm a little bit
overwhelmed because there's a lot more
braces brackets and parentheses that I'm
used to and that's true
um but well I'll try to highlight today
is like the big conceptual pieces and
how those align between the two um
because then we'll actually use some
starter code to help us create graphs in
a way that hopefully means we don't have
to get stuck on parentheses and curly
braces for example
so looking at these two minimum viable
uh code functional pieces of code side
by side the left in R and ggplot the
right in JavaScript and observable plot
what are the major pieces and how do
these align
um this first line in Orange in each if
it's ggplot or plot Dot Plot those are
doing the same thing it's initializing a
plot saying like we are creating a plot
now so that's the first piece right
that's one of like three major things we
need to tell each of these tools what's
the next thing the next thing is the
marks that we are using
um so in both of these cases we're not
specifying a chart type we're not saying
scatter plot we are saying this is the
mark that we're going to add to this
chart area to represent our data
visually
um because a DOT right whether it's
geompoint or plot dot dot those can add
a point and it can be a scatter plot but
it could also be a bubble chart on a map
right so we're not specifying the chart
type we're specifying the marks that
we're going to add to this plot area
based on the values of our data so
that's the second thing these specify
marks you'll notice here that that marks
in an observable plot is kind of
explicitly given its own
um key here so it says this is the mark
section because we can also do some
customization outside of marks that get
applied to the whole chart area
so that's the second thing is we specify
our marks whether it's G on point so
geoms in ggplot or these plot dot or
plot line or plot area marks in
observable plot
within that Mark we need to tell each of
these tools two things we need to say
okay what data are you pulling
information from and what are the
variables that you're plotting so how
are those How's data getting mapped into
this chart space for the X and Y axis uh
and that really is like these produce
the the same thing these both will
create a scatter plot of weight versus
miles per gallon from this car's data
set and we can see that these like major
building blocks are the same for each of
them
now there are some differences
um so I just wanted to show a few
comparisons I consider these things way
more similar than they are different
both in like how they're designed and
also in a lot of the vocabulary and
terminology
so this is just comparing some kind of
common uh options and marks that you
might see so if I look at the right to
columns if I want to change the fill
color of a shape I use fill in both but
if I want to change the outline color or
the line color
um in ggplot I use color in observable
plot that's stroke if I want to change
the size based on a constant or a
variable in ggplot we usually change the
size and in observable plot we use R for
radius
in GG plot to change opacity we use
Alpha in observable plot is just opacity
um and then looking further down at a
couple of the marks we can see that like
yeah they're different in the way that
that we type them out like we don't have
GM underscore under underscore and then
the actual Mark type
um but we just have like plot and then
or geom and then what the specific Mark
type is that we want to visually
represent our data using uh so I think
like yes there are differences and I
oftentimes will have to you know go back
and look look something up like oh this
what is this thing in r in ggplot mapped
onto this thing an observable plot but
overall like the options that are
available and how much you can customize
your chart are really really similar
across the two
um and if you want to check out an
interactive side-by-side comparison and
I'll go ahead and drop this in the chat
hopefully
copy link address uh then you can
maybe Gerald oh I'm not sure
um if that's sending the right thing
that didn't copy the the correct thing
but I'll send that along maybe
afterwards and that just provides a
side-by-side comparison and an
interactive view of
um basically like functioning ggplot
code customize ggplot code versus the
analogous code to create it with
observable plot
all right so I think that was under 10
minutes or close to it which I wanted to
keep it to for slides because I really
want this to mostly be like a showing
instead of telling session
um so I want to then uh share with you
all a notebook that I'm going to be
working in that you can work into
so I'm gonna copy
um this
URL
and I think I should be able to share it
though I always have kind of a hard time
um let me see if I can
so I'm not sure if that gets sent out to
everybody but maybe Jared if that
doesn't go to everyone on the call if
you um Can can share that with a group
on slack maybe that's there that would
be awesome yep I'll make sure and I'll
put on slack too like I'll get it
everywhere perfect thanks so much okay
so I want to first talk about what
you're looking at so when you click on
that link it should take you to a web
page that looks like this where is this
so this is an observable notebook
um observable notebooks are online
canvases where you can combine context
with text or images or links or whatever
so you can combine context with code and
the output so if you've been working in
other computational notebooks like our
markdown or Court show or Jupiter
notebooks this might feel similar
because the way that we create these is
in this notebook we add content that's
always within different cells so if
you're curious like how this text is
added if you ever click on the arrow to
the left of any of these cells that that
alligator mouth to the left then it will
reveal if it's not already pinned to
show up automatically it will reveal in
this case that this is created in
markdown so we have markdown cells but
there's also a bunch of other cell types
that you can add in an observable
notebook and if you want to see the many
different types if you want to insert a
new cell you can click on this plus
button anywhere in the margin where you
see a plus button and that brings up the
add sell menu so you can see right up
top kind of the three major cell types
JavaScript markdown and HTML but we also
have a lot of specials T cell types that
let you create create like really quick
interactive tables for example or like
we'll see later that actually give us
some skeleton code to create different
plot types and for just to show how this
can work if I do
plus and then look for a scatter plot
it's a searchable menu so as soon as I
start typing it'll narrow those results
if I press enter Then I it'll
automatically insert this JavaScript
cell and then if I run that either by
pressing this blue arrow or with shift
return then I'll see a scatter plot show
up and I can replace the data in
variables but that's just to show that
if you wanted to add more cells within
this notebook then you can press that
that little plus symbol and that's our
add sum on you to create new cells I'm
going to go ahead and delete this one
which I can just get to by clicking on
that vertical three dot menu anywhere
here
all right so what you might have noticed
hopefully hopefully I'm monologuing
how long has gotten a chance to make it
to this notebook what's kind of cool
about working these notebooks is whether
or not you have an observable account
you can follow along with the examples
that I'm doing today and that's because
notebooks have what's called a tinker
mode so you might have noticed that even
though you're not an editing author on
this notebook if you make changes to it
you would just see a banner up top
saying like hey heads up you're working
in Tinker mode your changes won't be
saved if you have an observable account
then you can Fork this notebook and
that'll store a copy with your changes
but for now if you don't have an account
that's all right I'll share the key so
you can still have everything that we've
done today but you can still follow
along and do everything that I do it'll
just be in Tinker mode
um so you could still try stuff out
okay so that is a little intro to
observable notebooks now let's go ahead
and get into observable plot
okay so if I scroll down to Activity one
and again you can follow me along if you
have a second screen or set these up
side by side
um the first activity we're gonna make a
horizontal bar chart and this is going
to be using uh data from the eia the U.S
Energy Information Administration and
I've already created a subset here
that's stored as energy underscore 2021
and in this it's actually stored as an
array in this array there are three
properties there's the type of energy
which is like the primary source there's
the year for this energy production
value and then there's the actual amount
created so in quadrillion DTU for that
source for that year what was the total
production across the country
so what we're going to do is this has
already been filtered to 2021 we're
gonna go ahead and we are going to make
an interactive chart uh with observable
plot but first we're going to make a
static chart
so the way that I'm going to do that is
and and if you ever get stuck on any of
this stuff in this notebook we have the
show me Buttons and if you just click
the arrow next to the show me it will
reveal the code that actually creates
the chart I'm going to make next so you
can copy that code paste it into a new
JavaScript cell which again you can get
to using this plus symbol and choosing
JavaScript and then run the code with
shift return or by pressing that blue
arrow so you should always be able to
create the charts that I'm making
okay but I'm going to start from pseudo
scratch not really but I'm going to
start by clicking on this add cell menu
and then I'm going to start by typing
horizontal and because I know that I
want to create a horizontal bar chart
so could I type this from a blank
JavaScript cell absolutely for time so
we can see a few more examples I'm going
to start with the snippet once I click
on that then it will populate with this
skeleton code a functional code that's
working I promise it still counts as
coding if you start from a plot snippet
um still is still a valid way to create
a chart but what are we actually seeing
here so this uses this this first line
is saying initialize the plot cool
that's like my ggplot line initialize
the plot
and then within this Marx option here
and then this merge option I'm telling
it what the different marks are that I
want to create so there's actually two
in this there's a horizontal bar which
is this plot.bar X and then there's this
plot rule X all this one is doing is
we'll see is this is creating a vertical
line at a value of zero
um so that's totally optional but we'll
see it when we run it this uses a
built-in data set that already exists
within an observable called alphabet
which has in it variables for letters of
the alphabet
and the frequency that those letters
show up in a sample data set of text it
also has some optional some options here
for actually sorting this to get those
bars in order from high to low so let's
go ahead and run this and you can see
that it creates this horizontal bar
chart
um what's nice about these plot code
skeletons is that I can then just
replace these placeholders in the
skeleton code with our data's data set
name and variables so here if I then
change this to and let me make sure what
I called this okay so this is called
Energy underscore 2021
so I'm going to change this data set
that's the first thing that plot bar X
needs to energy 2021 you can use tab
completion if you want here
the x-axis is going to be the amount
produced each year which is in
quadrillion underscore BTU that's that
variable name or that property key
and then why I'm going to have the type
so that's the type of energy and then if
I run this and again I can do shift
return or suppress that blue arrow
button in that cell then I can see that
I have an ordered horizontal bar chart
for these different types of energy one
thing that you'll notice is that there's
a default margin but we can customize
anything that we would want to hear so
oftentimes if you're working in ggplot
those will end up in like a an
overarching like theme section of your
plot
we're just going to put those right
within this plot.plot section of our
code but outside of the marks section
because this is being applied to the
entire chart area so outside of the
marks if I add a comma I'll press enter
just for vertical organization I can
change my margin left notice the camel
case here which you'll see all the time
in JavaScript including throughout
observable plot and I can increase that
maybe to like 200 pixels and then
that'll change that left margin
um I kind of think about a lot of
questions about options the way that I
do for ggplot like if I'm like can you
change this can I change this can I
change this the answer is yes
um and I just have to find a way to do
it so this is is fully customizable uh
so just to make one more change I'm
going to go ahead and add a fill color
as a constant but up in this Mark so
this is going to be a fill that's
applied to this plot bar X so it could
be anywhere within here but I'm going to
add it right after y I'm gonna say I
want to make the fill color red
and I could add a stroke option so I
could have a stroke I could change the
opacity here using the opacity option
again ranging from zero to one like it
does in ggplot but for now we have this
static chart that has a constant fill
color
um but what I want to do is let's
quickly make this interactive for this
first one we're going to be doing
something that is like maybe not
functionally super valuable but does
highlight kind of the lightweightness of
adding interactivity to a chart created
with observable plot when you're working
in JavaScript
and the way that we're going to do that
is to create a an interface element or a
widget using what are called observable
inputs and observable inputs are the
observable version of pre-made widgets
um so if I come up here right above my
chart I'm going to create this widget
right above this chart so I'm going to
click that add cell menu and I'm going
to search for color because I know that
there is an existing input that lets you
choose a color from a palette and we'll
return the value of a hexadecimal color
code
when I select that then this will
automatically create this again code for
a default widget and if I run that then
that widget shows up in my notebook
this blue pin here means that the actual
code is pinned if I want to hide it I
can always just click on that blue pin
and then that won't be shown by default
but then I can reveal it again if I want
to work there and I can re-pin it if I
want that to always show up by default
so here what's happening a couple of
important things are happening is first
this creates a new widget this
inputs.color this creates this specific
color widget but there's also like
inputs radio radio buttons and for
checkboxes and drop down menus and text
inputs and a whole bunch of other things
but here this is a specific one that
lets you choose a color
so you can notice that there's like you
can change the label for it maybe I'll
say like pick a color and that just
changes the label that shows up to the
left of it I can change the default
value that's what this value option does
here so here maybe I'll make this
coffee
um so that's my terrible default color
but a key here is that when you create
an input that's not only creating the
widget but it's also storing the value
of the current selection so this isn't
necessary but just to like show you
what's happening is I'm essentially
creating a dynamic variable where here
if I call color then anywhere else
what's actually stored in color because
that's the name of the widget here is
the value of the current selection so as
I like move this around then you can see
that the value stored as color is also
changing along with it and this is cool
because this gives us a tool this gives
us a variable that is connected that is
connected to the input selection that I
can just call wherever I want to then
change my chart or text or table
filtering or whatever
so to make my chart interactive here
instead of saying I want the fill color
to be this static red I'm just going to
say I want the fill to actually be based
on this hexadecimal color code that is
the current color value and when I do
that then I can see that not only does
it update here but now as I move around
in this widget that I can see that the
value of color is updated as I move it
and that is actually what's being used
as the fill color
um so is this functionally critical no
but the takeaway I hope is that like the
process of adding interactivity
using observable to a chart is create
the widget and give it a name using
observable inputs
that gets automatically stored as a
value that is the name of that widget in
this case color and then you can use
that wherever else you want in charts or
wherever else as this interactive or
dynamic variable that's changing based
on the user selection and since we're
already on the web working in the
language of the web this is an
automatically shareable interactive
chart like if I just sent this to
somebody just with the link then they
would be able to play with this so so
there's no like rendering and then
hosting this somewhere it's already good
to go as an interactive chart and
there's a lot of options if you're
working in observable uh to embed your
different pieces in different ways so
you can either download charts but you
can also embed them in other websites
like your blogs or other sites that you
might want to add them to so it becomes
easy pretty lightweight to add
interactivity and also to then share
interactive pieces
okay so that's a first example
um the second example where we'll do
something that that hopefully is a is a
little bit more functionally relevant
when we add interactivity
um but also we're going to learn just a
few like core JavaScript script
Essentials
so I'm gonna scroll down to this second
activity
um so this is from the data set except
now I haven't filtered to only include
data from 2021 so you can see here in
this data table cell uh we have still
our different types or different primary
sources for the different energy
um but we also have this across
different years and we still have
quadrillion BTUs as the units for how
much we've produced for each energy type
for each year so what we're going to do
now that we have this longitudinal data
is create a line chart for each of these
different sources to see patterns in how
they've been changing over time and then
we're going to add interactivity that
lets us highlight one of those at a time
there's not so many groups that this is
like an overwhelming spaghetti plot but
it can still be nice to highlight and
especially if we had a lot more types
then it can be really nice to just
highlight one series at a time for
example
so that's what we're going to do in this
next example
so we're going to start first a static
line chart of each of these energy
sources over time and then we'll add
interactivity and that's where we will
learn some JavaScript Essentials
so I'll start and again that show me
button is here um if you get stuck at
any point but I'm going to start by
clicking this insert cell button and
it's searchable so once I'm in that add
cell menu I can start typing line
and I can see that the first option is
to create a line chart of values over
time which is what we want to do but you
can see there's a bunch of different
options so I'll choose this first one to
create a line sharp again this is
already functional code this uses Apple
closing value I think for Apple stocks
uh if I run this this uses an existing
data set
so I could do that but we want to use
our US Energy data so to do that I'll
make sure so this is called energy
production that's how I've stored this
data set
so I'm going to replace in my line Y I'm
going to replace that Apple data set
with energy production or data and then
I need to replace my X and Y variables
so that it's not what this pre-populated
code was in the snippet
um to say on the x-axis I'm going to use
that variable that's stored as year and
on the y-axis I'm going to use our
quadrillion BTU again
and when I run this you might see
something that is familiar if you've
been working in ggplot which is like why
are you not recognizing these different
series sometimes this will show up in
ggplot you'll see these like vertical
line steps it's like what's happening
and then and then realize like oh right
it like this code has no idea that there
is another variable in this data that's
helpful to differentiate between the
different series and that's what we need
to provide this plot code so just to
talk through this again I am
initializing a plot this is the
equivalent of GG plot in a ggplot code
and then I have plot rule all this plot
rule zero
zero is doing is creating this
horizontal line at y equals zero but if
I get rid of that so I'll just comment
that out which in JavaScript is just a
double backslash
um then like there's there's no more
horizontal line it's hard to tell since
there's some of these some of these
series are right along the um that
access anyway but that just removes that
x-axis
all right so I have uh within this Mark
saying like how am I visually
representing this data I'm creating a
line chart
um you've using data from energy
production where I have this new object
saying what my x-axis variable is and
which is year and what my y-axis
variable is which is in quadrillion BTU
but I also need to tell it like okay
this is the variable that actually can
be used to differentiate different
series here and I can do that by setting
a stroke just like if you set a color
aesthetic in ggplot it'll automatically
recognize like oh if that's based on a
variable then these are going to be
treated as different series but I can
also set that here using Z so I can say
Z I want to say differentiate these
different series based on the type
columns so that type property
all right so currently
um and we could we could label these we
could add a legend we can we can
customize this however we want
um what I want to do next is let's go
ahead and make this interactive by
creating radio buttons of these
different energy types and whichever one
a user chooses from those radio buttons
that's going to get highlighted in red
well the rest of these series are in
Gray so that's going to be our next step
is to add interactivity
um just as a reminder again the show me
code is here that'll get you to
essentially like very close to to what
we've created above so you can get back
on on track there
okay so let's make this interactive
again I am going to go right above this
chart because that's where I want my
widget to show up
um one thing that well there's a couple
things here that I just want to
acknowledge might feel a little bit
um unfamiliar if you've been working in
our markdown or in quarto docs or in
Jupiter notebooks is that when you're
when you're working in an observable
notebooks the output shows up
immediately above the the cell where
you've written the code and another
Major Way the observable notebooks work
differently is that the code runs
topologically which means that you can
put cells in any order that you want to
and it will just look to wherever other
cells that it depends on are in the
notebook so you don't unlike R where
like if you want to use something that
um if C requires b and a then b and a
have to be earlier on in the code that's
not the case for observable books you
can have things exist in whatever order
you want throughout the notebook so I
know that those are a little bit
unfamiliar
okay so let's go ahead and create this
new widget I'm going to click on this
add cell menu again and I'm going to
start typing radio because that's gonna
produce this input so again this is
called an observable input which is
these like pre-created widgets made in
JavaScript
and that's going to when I select it if
I just run what's created out of the box
it creates a widget with A and B so
important thing here this is called
radios so if I call you don't have to do
this but if I then later on say hey give
me the value of radios then that just
stores the current selection in this
radio so you can see it switching
between a and b
but we can see here that the way that I
create these different buttons that a
user can choose from is by creating an
array of the different possible choices
so this is bounded by square brackets so
this is a JavaScript array if I add C
here then there's three options
but we don't want to we could here
manually type like solar and we could
manually type like all the different
types we could put into our array but
instead we're going to use a little bit
of JavaScript code so I'm going to
explain this as I go
so I want to from this energy production
data set
I want to access all of the different
unique types of energy and I want those
to be what show up in this radio buttons
widget
so to do that I'm going to as this first
element I'm going to say hey starting
from energy production then I'm going to
use an array map method which has a
specific job so I'm going to use that by
using dot map
and then I have open and close
parentheses
and Mac has a specific job that is to
iterate over each element in an array
and return something based on the
outcome of a function that's within this
map method so this is just iterating
over every object in that energy
production data set which in our case we
can think of as every row
the next thing I'm going to do and this
is another JavaScript essential is I'm
going to use what's called an arrow
function to access just the type columns
value so that'll just get me an array of
all of the different types that show up
in that type column and to do that this
is called an arrow function this is just
a concise way of writing a function
where I say like hey for a parameter D
which in our case is each of those
different rows
I want to access you'll sometimes hear
this called an access or function I want
to access the value in the type column
so again if I just ran this and I'm not
going to if you press strand already
that's okay but if I just run this this
is going to return every single value in
the type column whether or not it
repeats because it's iterated over each
row and accessed the type value
but luckily there's also an option
within inputs to say I want to only show
each thing each thing once which is to
add within this object where I can add
these options is to say unique true
and so if I run that then what I get is
this widget that now has each of my
different possible sources
and notice that here it says choose the
default value of a but that doesn't
match any of the things that are up here
so I'm going to change this to one that
does exist so I'll change the default
value to coal and that means that my
coal will be selected by default
but I can see then as I switch these I
can see that the values that radio is
storing is also changing
so as I select around that's just
storing a different
um value as radios and you can change
the name too like if I wanted to change
this I could change this to pick source
for example
let's go ahead and change this in our
chart so what I'm going to do now is I'm
actually going to change the stroke
color of these lines so that it depends
on that user selection and again this
pattern is like I've created a chart
that I've created a widget I've created
an element using inputs that's going to
store a value based on user selection
and then because that value is stored by
that input name I can call that back to
use it as a way to make my my plots or
my text or whatever Interactive
so here I'm going to go ahead and do
that with the the stroke the line color
and this is going to be the third
JavaScript programming essential that
we're going to cover I think this is the
last one so we'll just do these three
but to change the line color I want this
to be conditional so I want to say if
the if the series name so if the type
here matches that user selection so if
that matches this value of radios then I
want the line to be red so if if the
value of the type matches the radio
selection I want it to be red if not I
want it to be gray we're going to use
what's called a ternary operator here
and to do that this is essentially the
same as an if else statement in our or
other programming languages I'm going to
write a little function that says Okay I
want to access the type
value from each of my rows
and if that value matches radios so if
that matches the current selection of
radios
then and then you have a question so you
say like hey does the type value match
radios if true do this first thing
immediately after the question mark then
I want the stroke to be red
if not then we have a single colon then
I want the line to be a light gray or
you could type gray or you could type
yellow here so any valid web color codes
or hexadecimal codes will work here make
sure you have this comma at the end of
this line
and now when I run this because I have
this if else statement written using the
ternary operator that asks hey if the
type value matches radios then make it
red otherwise make the stroke light gray
then when I run this then I can see that
when I change these and I'll unpin this
so we can see it all in one place then
as I change these we can see that only
the value only only the series where it
matches the user selection for radios is
actually showing up as red and
everything else is showing up as light
gray
um so it's kind of cool right like this
is like really two steps to an
interactive and shareable chart that you
can make you make the chart make the
widget with a name that input stores a
value that's Dynamic based on the user
selection and then you can use that
Dynamic variable for that input anywhere
else you want to to create an
interactive chart
all right
um so we're going to do one more which
is let's let's make a map uh and more we
can make an interactive map which will
be cool
let's go ahead because I don't want to
to spend too long I know that these
these virtual sessions can feel like
they're dragging so I want to be done
presenting on this by the hour
um so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
ahead and copy this code and I'll talk
through it a little bit but if you go
ahead to the show me code copy it create
a new JavaScript cell and then paste it
in there
then this code creates a map so again
all I've done here is I've copied that
Activity three show me code from the
show me option I've copied that code
pasted it into a JavaScript cell and
then when I run it then I see this map
show up of the US
um to talk through this this is also
just like following like a grammar of
Graphics to build piece by piece what we
want to be represented in this map I
initialize the plot the one additional
piece with spatial data is letting it
that I am including here is letting it
know how this information from a sphere
should be mapped on to 2D space this is
using Albers USA But like I could change
this to Mercator it's not going to be
great but now we have a Mercator
Projection
um but I'll change this back to Albers
USA
and but you can use the different
built-in projections and we have
documentation to to show you how
um but then what's happening within the
marks well here I have two marks the
first one is just creating this
background United States map which pulls
from uh States data that I had imported
later on in the notebook we can use it
here because order doesn't matter but I
had imported it previously
um and then this just provides some
aesthetic customization so I have this
light gray line around each state but
the polygon fills are white and I've
made the stroke with a little bit
narrower
so that would just if I just did that
that would create
um that would create just the US base
map here and then on top of that and
again following the grammar of graphics
on top of that I'm adding this other
Mark I'm adding on top of it this plot
dot dot which is used to actually create
the bubbles
and for a little bit of context what
this is plotting is each of these
locations are a different Power plan in
the United States from this U.S
underscore plants data set that I had
already pre-loaded here so you have a
longitude latitude for each we also have
the total capacity and the primary
source for that plant so here
I have
um what we're showing here is we have
each point the location the the centroid
of each point is based on the latitude
longitude and latitude for each of those
uh but I also have a fill color based on
the primary source so each of these fill
colors represents a different plant type
um I have
each of these the same level but but
this uh slightly translucent Circle
um down here what I'm doing is is
updating some of these scales so this
line notice that it's outside of the
mark but this is setting a new range of
sizes for the different circles you'll
notice if I comment that out then those
circles just have a different size range
so you can constrain the scale across
which these different channels are
actually mapped
um and I've updated the color scheme
but here what I want to do is just show
that like how what we've already learned
also works for a map so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to get rid of this
line to update the color Channel you
don't have to actually it'll work just
fine this takes me back to a default
color scheme and let's go ahead and make
this interactive
um so again what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create radio buttons again this
could also be check boxes or a drop down
menu with multiple selections or
something I'm going to change the name
of this to say like pick Source now
that's going to be the value that gets
stored
and I'm going to do my little JavaScript
data wrangling again using a map and an
arrow function to JavaScript Essentials
that we're already using here
so this is from us plants I'm going to
iterate over each row or each object in
that array which looks like a
rectangular table in that data table
cell above
and I'm going to say from each of those
I want to access the primary underscore
Source value primary underscore source
so that would return every single value
of primary source
but to make sure I only return each once
I'm going to add unique true as one of
my options here and now I can see that I
just have each one of my sources
represented one single time and then
maybe I'll change the default selection
to solar
so this is just creating
um based on an existing call you could
write these out manually but this is
just programmatically creating these
radio buttons based on the unique levels
within that primary source column of our
data
okay so this remember is stored as pick
Source here now this gives us a a
variable that stores whatever this user
has selected which means that then down
in my map I can again say okay well
instead of the fill color being based on
a different color for each primary
source if I just want to highlight one
at a time then I'm going to again use my
ternary operator so I'm going to say hey
look in the primary source column
so that's what this little accessor
function is doing is as you iterate
through each row in this data look in
the primary source column and ask does
that match the value that's currently
selected from that pick Source input
because we had named that input pixource
and if that returns true so I have a
question mark I say is that true then do
this thing immediately after the
question mark so I'll say make that red
but if that's false then I can return
let's say like yellow to make this
totally horrendous
so again this is just using a ternary
operator to say if the primary source
matches the user selection then I want
it to stand out in red otherwise I want
that to be in yellow this is going to
look really bad let's run it anyway
okay so he can see yes sure enough yeah
I can't I can't stand it I'm changing it
to to my light gray okay but you but you
see what happens is that now we have
again
we have
um a way that we can pretty quickly
create this interactive map that shows
where these different sources are you
might be wondering at this time like oh
I noticed that the one I've selected
shows up behind some of these you can
change it so that
um in the in the first position so the
one plotted on top you can change the
domain order so that it won't be behind
these but another option too is to play
with opacity just like we would play
with the fill color so as a last
interactivity example
I'm gonna say hey I also want opacity to
be interactive so I'm going to add a new
option for opacity where again I'm going
to say does the primary source
primary source match what's selected in
that pixource input and if it does if if
that is true if it matches that user
selection I want it to be completely
opaque so that means if it matches the
user selection here it will be opaque
red and if not then I want it to be
pretty
translucent so I'll make that 0.2
because 1 is completely opaque zero is
completely transparent so this is going
to put anything that doesn't match the
user selection towards the more
transparent side
and then if I run this
then I'll be able to see that when I
make selections then I can see that not
only do my my opacity is not changing
here
hmm
which I feel like I'm doing something
wrong because only the
interesting only the
[Music]
um
selected sources should be should be
showing up totally
um okay instead of opacity a few lines
later
thank you thank you look at that
Teamwork Makes the Dream work okay so
that was over which is the like great to
point out right like this will not throw
an error but whatever comes later in the
code will override what Maya had done to
to make this work earlier on thank you
so much now that I've gotten rid of that
duplicate opacity that was overriding
what I was doing now I can see that both
the opacity and the fill color that
those are both changing based on my user
selection I'm using that nice ternary
operator so as I select these now I can
really see patterns on where things
exist like we can see like a
concentration of wind power plants along
the wind belts we can see a lot of
hydroelectric power plants along the
Sierra Nevada and up into the
on the west coast so we can really start
seeing patterns for these different
Power Plant primary sources
so to to reiterate this was just three
examples that I hope captured that like
the way that we build visualizations
with observable plot follows the grammar
of Graphics really really closely to the
way that you might have been building
charts in ggplot so that's the first
thing is that your knowledge of of the
grammar of Graphics in ggplot really
truly does map really nicely to get you
up and running quickly and observable
plot and second that inputs in
JavaScript those give us a lightweight
way to make interactive data
visualizations by creating the the input
that stores a value and creates the
input at the same time and then we can
call the name of that input later on and
then based on that input's value which
is the user selection then that'll
update our chart or our text or a table
or whatever else we've connected that
input to
so I am going to stop there
um and I'll I'll stop sharing my screen
I think and maybe we can hop into some
questions
well first of all thank you very much
and I'll give you a clap here Golf Club
hopefully everyone else can do an emoji
clap
um I had a fantastic time watching that
and I'm sure that everyone else did as
well
thank you
very welcome
so let's ask a few questions here I have
a bunch of different ones collated from
different sources
um but first question about observable
is this free is it unlimited use how do
I how do people you know get charged for
this
great question so yeah you can have a um
free account
the there are uh limits on like how much
data you can upload like file size per
notebook and I think also a monthly
quota
um so there are a couple of different
reasons why you might want to upgrade to
the paid account although you can like
try it out play in JavaScript create all
your plots like you can do that for free
um but the if if you wanted to work in
private notebooks then that's when you
get into the paid tiers
um and there's also like increases
depending on the tier that you're
working in
um changes in the amount of data that
you can upload and sort of the monthly
quotas for for file sizes and and
uploads and stuff but but yeah to just
get started free sign up if you're happy
working publicly
um then you can absolutely just get
started
I'll also just add like I spent a lot of
years feeling like I needed to learn
JavaScript and then I would
get immediately too intimidated by like
node and console log it's like I can't
uh this is too much I'm not a web
developer
um so working in observable is a great
way to get started without feeling like
that you can just start like like upload
a file and start playing with the data
in a JavaScript cell like that's all
there is to it
um so if it made me feel like I could be
successful learning JavaScript as a
person who didn't come from a web
development background
yeah try it out and let us know reach
out if we can help like reach out to me
I can point you in the right directions
but yeah if you go to observablehq.com
then that's where you can see our
options for signing up
even the little kids want to learn it I
know right every who doesn't who doesn't
want to do some JavaScript for data work
yep
so does the computations happen in my
browser or on the observable servers
yeah so we don't actually
um it's it's on all in your browser uh
so like whatever is happening like in
observable the is where like the code is
stored but like the processing of that
we don't see on our end
um so yeah even if you're like
if you connect to a database for example
through observable
um like in your notebook on observable
if you're like working and see either
SQL cells too so if you're like working
in SQL and observable then your SQL code
might be stored there but like we
actually don't see like the the process
or the outputs or even the data
um is is on your end
okay
cool
um then
can I run this like in V like it's not
like this in vs code on my computer or
does it need to be through the browser
yeah only
browser based all right and I don't want
to get this wrong but a way that like
I've experienced this that you might
notice just in case so nobody gets
thrown off is last time I checked and
they might have made updates but like
for example working in our studio in a
quarto dock right I'm working in a qmd
you can add the JavaScript cell but like
when you you can't like run it locally
like you can with like an R cell and see
the output show up
um so to see the output I think I was
like rendering and then once I opened it
in the browser you could actually see
the the outputs from the OJs cells so
just a heads up if you're if you're
trying to in quarto
um know that like you're not working in
the browser so like you can't see or at
least it was like this and if somebody's
on that that is has tried it more
recently or knows more if you please
feel free to chime in but I think even
there you're still like rendering it but
then opening it in the browser is when
you can actually see the the outputs of
the code that you've added
and JSL is different than an ojsl
I've only ever used an ojsl so if there
is a if there is a JSL then
um yeah okay so yeah there are I'll try
to find a link there are ways
um that observable JavaScript differs a
little bit from vanilla JavaScript
they're very similar like if you learn
JavaScript in an observable notebook
then like you are learning JavaScript
like it is Javascript one time I asked
Mike boss talk I was like is it like
JavaScript with some sprinkles and he
said that's about as close as you're
gonna get so
think of it as like JavaScript with
sprinkles
um but we have this notebook uh that
I'll share that describes
um the difference between them and
they're they're pretty minimal
um and a lot of them are related to
um changes that were made so that the
reactive runtime that observable uses
actually works including that like cells
can be out of order when you run them so
um so there's a link yeah if if you want
to share that that kind of describes
those minimal differences between
vanilla JavaScript and uh the uh
JavaScript with sprinkles that is
observable JavaScript
okay
stick in the whole Porto and JavaScript
thread here
um if I have a r data frame or for that
matter a panda's data frame can I plot
that in the ojsl
yes but it needs to go through and again
last I checked and things are changing
quickly so dough like things might have
changed since then
um but you use a function
um OJs underscore Define I think that's
what it is uh to actually convert your
um our object into an object that is
understood by observable plot for
example so you can work between the two
but it's like one step to make something
that you created like a data frame and R
available for use in an OJs cell yeah
and I think it's OJs underscore Define
um but I know it's in the Porto docs how
how you can work between the two and
that sounds like an R function not a
JavaScript function yeah yep so it's in
your car cell where that happens yeah
okay because let's say you say like my
DF gets ogs underscore defined Mt cars
then in JavaScript you would reference
it as my DF yep uh yeah exactly then
that's what you could use
there is one other step that for me I
found
share another example to
um
so also I'll share an example that uh
uh
as I'm sharing and I'm like why are you
sharing this but that's fine
um so this uh is a post that I did
um that has some like optical character
recognition
and data wrangling in R and then passes
that into some OJs cells so this entire
post is made in a quarto document for my
site
and yeah if you scroll down you'll see
like it's all rrr and then you get to a
point
um where down where it says this those
this is a fake data set on bird attacks
um anyway but then you see where I use
OJs Define to actually make these usable
uh in OJs cells and then there's a
second step which isn't technically
mandatory but for my brain it was a
little bit easier which was to transpose
that data
um because sometimes like they're under
the hood like
it is it is a bit different like if we
think about variables and data frames
and columns in Array those are objects
so so it's it's a little bit different
so you can transpose although I show
both ways in that post um Phil who's on
our team who's like oh you don't
actually have to transpose it to use it
in plot so there's there's both examples
there
so imagine it's because it's so by
default if you move it from R to
JavaScript it's going to be column wise
bony transpose it you make it row wise
yeah exactly yep cool and somewhere West
McKinney is crying you're not using a
column based data store
well I think I think Phil like Phil
truly was like
okay so Phil here in in this comment so
I'll just read this because I also was
confused so I'll try to follow up about
this too so I don't break any cards
because when I first posted this I was
like oh like my my my column loving
heart hurts that I have to transpose
this and then Phil's like no no no
actually you don't like don't have a
broken heart it can accept untransposed
data
um you just have to like specify the
variables in a slightly different way
within plot to account for that but you
absolutely can use it
um just depends on I guess your
preference for for which way you do it
JavaScript using the map might not work
because that's mapping over an array of
objects yeah that might not like going
over a column yep even though memory
wise would be better but hey all right
what are we gonna do
cool all right all right so then some
specifics about the types of plots so
you talked about a legend can the legend
be generated automatically if you say
fill equals a column name can
automatically generate the Legend all
right yeah absolutely so
um
maybe I'll just show an example so
um if that works
so let me go back to this line chart and
I'm going to change it back from my
static from my Dynamic version and I'm
going to say I want the stroke to
actually be based on type
um ggplot and add a comma
ggplot by default does add a legend when
you specify when you map a variable to
an aesthetic
um in plot that's not the default so we
just have to like manually specify that
so here I'll just say or the color
Channel I'm going to make sure to
override the legend false setting
um and then I can have a legend show up
and you can customize this you can
customize the swatches you can change
the color scheme like you would expect
to you can change the layout of it
um so absolutely you can add Legends
based on variables map to chart
Aesthetics and like plotly can make us
take a click on the legend to filter out
what's in the chart
ooh can you click on the legend not that
I know of that's a great question
what you could do is make a a custom
input where like the Swatch is just part
of the check box like the color swatch
that that then could be used to select
the different options
um so you could make a custom one which
is kind of a nice thing about working in
JavaScript is kind of like ideal for
making those lightweight interactive
things yeah good question but there
might be something that is built already
and I might just not know about it fair
enough
all right
um I'm going to plot specific things in
a second so there's a question I meant
to ask earlier
um can you embed these plots either like
a regular website or maybe even more
difficult a WordPress website
excellent question yes so I think
observable makes it pretty nice
um so if I go back and share my screen
hopefully you can see this for any named
cell so here and here like by name cell
I mean like truly give it a name so if I
call this like my chart
for any named cell that doesn't show
change what shows up just make gives it
a name
if you click on that vertical three dot
menu there's built-in embed options
um and if you click that then you can
select the different elements the
different named elements that you would
want to embed anywhere else either using
iframe or with react for example so you
can then just copy the code or copy the
URL and and then just like embed that
directly into another site and I haven't
tried it you can see you can also do the
entire notebook you can make observable
notebooks into JavaScript modules
there's like a lot of options for reuse
you can import pieces which is so cool
and another session totally so it won't
get totally derailed here
um but yeah you can any name sell you
can just click that embed button select
the pieces you want to embed including
if it's interactive and then go ahead
and add that to your site I haven't
tried it specifically in WordPress but I
I think that this should work as
expected there WordPress can be
difficult with JavaScript you have to
jump through a whole bunch of Hoops
maybe not I don't know what Hoops you
would need to make this work
I'll
write that down is if WordPress makes
problems
cool thanks for the question
I know this we have other questions this
is actually one that I was thinking of
um I was watching you do a tutorial
about this stuff and chaining together a
bunch of function calls like dot map Dot
filter.net and you notice that if I were
doing it in the Chrome console it auto
completes like after each function I do
a dot it knows what's available for the
next methods and members I didn't see
that working in observable am I doing
something wrong or can you not change
not get autocomplete for chaining
um for some of the methods I don't think
I know how to answer that question uh so
I mean um for doing like data wrangling
steps for so I think that that in some
cases there are
um so let me
just check
um and I'll just show my screen so you
can all see me Play Alive because what
is more fun than just seeing people
flail around okay so if I share my
screen
um tell you the types of methods that
are available here
um so like like map comes up here and
then I could do
my map of the of whatever D um
but I notice here like
so here it's giving me
um autofill options for
what I could populate after this but
maybe since this isn't like a recognized
array then it's not automatically
bringing up the array functions or the
array methods
um or if I have objects then I would I
think it brings up the methods that work
on objects for example
um so yeah I don't have a good answer
besides I think like if you have an
array it should tell you what the array
methods are and if you have an object
then I think it will tell you what the
object methods are
um but beyond that I'm not exactly sure
what the the different limitations are
for like the preview of what's available
um because maybe it may be for some of
those like an accessor function it
doesn't make a prediction about what
it's expecting but yeah great question
let's say you did map let's say in I
know that you can't do D dot column name
unless they did the math then after the
closing parenthesis dot then another map
or another filter or whatever I don't
think it's autocompleting there oh okay
so let's try so if I do D and then like
type here whatever and then
D here oh so maybe oh interesting so
you'd expect here because that's just an
array that that would also give tell you
what to do huh maybe it's maybe it's
stuff that won oh that would be cool to
look into no I I am not sure what is
underlying the algorithm for when that
shows up but that's a great question
um yeah because it doesn't show up for
me either yeah good point from console
so I'm saying this is a feature request
to make it work here too oh no that
sounds great yeah I really appreciate it
cool cool then I'm going to continue on
then hopefully not feature requests
we'll never know
um can you modify the plot Aesthetics
with CSS
yeah so you can create your own style
sheets that get applied
um in different places so you can fully
customize uh different pieces
um with CSS I think a lot of
um a lot of the options that you want to
customize
um
are probably like built-in options
within plot so I can send you I'm going
to send you the flat sheet sheets
because they're pretty cool too
so for the observable plot cheat sheets
I think these are awesome
um these will give you an idea in an
interactive way of what the different
options are but you can not only
customize using the built-in options but
like it's just JavaScript code so you
can like fully customize with whatever
additional JavaScript code you wanted to
add like within plot here
um so
cool
you can you can continue speaking I'm
just uh pasting the code my keyboard's
allowed so I wanted to let you know cool
let me um find one example custom
um elements
just trying to find one example
uh where we
update theme elements
um
and we do actually do some some CSS to
like change the fonts and things
so here is an example where I think in
this one uh we use some CSS to to update
the Styles um like for fonts and font
sizes but you could do that for I think
color schemes too and stuff cool thank
you
um all right so then I know um
originally like D3 I think I used SVG as
the underlying um technology and that
can get swamped with large data sets so
I guess a what if I made a scatter plot
of like the diamonds data 50 000 points
can I do that and if not can I use like
a webgl to render this
yeah that's a great question
um so I don't know webgl
um so I can't answer that part
um
usually I've found that plot does all
right up to around like
eighty thousand
points okay
um after that I've noticed sometimes it
gets a little bogged down and I might
just get like a spinning wheel uh but 70
80 000 is maybe like an upper limit of
what
blot might be happy about
okay
and I guess you're applying something
like a map with polygons each vertex
counts against that limit so if you have
20 000 polygons but each one has ten
edges 10 nodes and that could that could
hit you it could yeah I think I haven't
tried it I haven't tried it I think like
most of the like base Maps I've been
using
um which I think is kind of nice for for
a lot of like the standard base Maps
observable already has those built in so
they're like
like pretty nice shapes but also not
gonna bog it down so there's like a
world map US map you can get the
counties from that
um but yeah I mean I I would assume and
again I don't want to say without
knowing exactly what those limitations
would be but I think if you had like
really high resolution spatial polygons
you'd probably end up like reaching uh
reaching a similar limit there okay yeah
and then let's talk about the math and
mentioned it can I like put the
observable pot like on top of a leaflet
style map so it's slippy like a zoom in
pan
you can
um so you see leaflet and that's
something that I haven't done too yeah
bringing up all kinds of awesome things
um but yeah you can absolutely use use
leaflet in observable notebooks um what
I haven't done is
um observable plot with leaflets uh and
and what that that looks like so but I
think
it would be awesome
um I haven't tried it previously but
yeah happy to look and check with the
team and then send along whatever
resources that we have
perfect yeah
um let's see what else we got here
all right is there a reason like what
was the design choice that the output is
above the code not below it
great question
um so I don't want to speak for anybody
else at the observable team
um who have been like very intentional
about like designing the product and and
and so I think there's like
um documentation that speaks to this
um but what I will share is that it's
kind of a a shift in mentality that like
the priority in notebooks is going to be
the outputs and people getting insights
from the outputs and then secondary to
that is see the code if you want to
um and I think that's just not that
that's not possible by having like a
hidden code chunk and then only the uh
the output show up but I think it it
like shows the intentionality of like
the prioritization of the output that
people are going to see first with the
code that's created that you would see
below and not the other way around
um I think both work really well I think
it's like mostly was like an adjustment
I was like I have never seen this before
my output is always immediately beyond
my code and uh no I don't even think
about it I'm like oh of course of course
that's where it shows up but it
definitely was a little bit of a
surprise when when I first saw things
showing up above the cells I was writing
in
threw me for a while too I kept watching
like what is this going on here then
event when when actually I heard you say
it one time like okay no it makes sense
I know what's going on
all right cool
um in your columns you mention them when
you do marks you give them as quotations
not bear names so not like ggpot right
how do you take the log of a column if
the column is in quotes
yeah so you can do it a couple of
different ways
um so you can actually do transforms
right within observable plot so instead
of for example like
like
um X quadrillion BTUs if I wanted to
transform that I would just use my
accessor notation I could do like d
Arrow function D dot quadrillion BTUs
divided by a thousand or something so I
can like add JavaScript code to access
and transform a variable right within my
plot code
um so that's one way so if you want to
actually transform the value of the
variables and plot that you can do it
outside of your plot code you can do it
within the plot code with a with an
accessor function to transform that but
you can also actually just change the
scale that's visually plotted so like if
I change
um I'll just just show this one for
example here if I wanted to make the
y-axis a log scale then I could add here
and just like type and then add log here
um so I could put it visually on a log
scale that's not actually transfer
forming the data or I could do within
this y Channel I could do like d d and
then say like two D quadrillion BTU and
then whatever the D3 probably function
is to transform this to I don't know if
it's like D3 log or something I'm
guessing that's not it but however I
wanted to transform that I could do that
right in that y Channel okay so either
one of those or do it outside of plot
and then use the updated transform data
so I think there's a couple of different
ways to transform data either like
actually transform or visually show
transform skills
while you have your browser still
sharing uh
um how would you make a hover tool tip
over that line chart could you hover
over it and
absolutely so if I wanted to add that
um the way that I have added it here and
again I will share my screen is
um there is in observable one really
cool thing that like this is a great
question to highlight this is any
notebook that you can see that you have
access to
you can access pieces from it like
functions or charts or whatever or
arrays of data using what's called an
import so the way that I think about
this is like imagine if any
are markdown notebook you looked at you
were like oh I should use that function
and instead of being like okay I'm
either going to manually copy the whole
function or I'm going to like fork and
clone the re access to it if it's not in
a package or whatever instead you just
use this import and then you tell it
what named thing from any other visible
notebook in the observable Multiverse of
tens of thousands more than that
notebooks exist so this is a cell called
add tool tips from Mike Freeman's plot
tooltip code
um and I can then just use that so this
one this function that Mike created uh
you can go ahead and wrap around a your
plot code so I can just do add tool tips
around my entire plot code and then if I
give my I'm going to get rid of this log
scale because that's just
gonna drive me up the wall
um then what I can do is if I add a
title Channel then this will create the
tool tip so if I just do like title and
then
um I don't know let's see what what
happens here nope that's not gonna work
uh I might have to look up Mike's code
here because there's something
interesting
um about how these are created
a soda in a second and this is Mike
Freeman uh formerly viewed up right yes
Mike uh yeah so yeah and who does a ton
of awesome data visualization
[Music]
um
so he's another who's also is is a
background in our but here for example I
have this title now
um where I can customize this so I can
say these are uh template literals which
means that I can have running JavaScript
code within a string so I can say I want
this to start with the type and then
um have the quadrillion BTUs since it's
wrapped and add tool tips then when I
hover over these then I can see that
those would show up over that and
there's in Mike's notebook different
options for applying tool tips over
um all the plots in your all of the
plots in your notebook or just one which
I've done here by wrapping this one
nice yeah that seems like a nice easy
way to do it
um just one or two marks I know we are
going a little long
um when you made your bar chart it was
like you had to specify like the Y act
so in this case the x is horizontal you
know GM bar and ggplot can count for you
you give it a discrete X it'll count for
you can you do that here
yeah so the way that you do that is
um
you can specify groupings or binnings so
for example if I had
um
and I was just making an example of this
earlier today so I wonder if I still
have it up but like of course I don't
um but
yeah actually I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna show this one great okay I did
kind of have this up
so here's an example of what that can
look like this is using the Penguins
data set
so here I'm making a bar chart
um but you can also designate how you
want to group things and then give it a
reducing function so here I'm saying I
want to group along like the x-axis
variable which here is by species and
this is doing some sorting but that's
optional so I'm just going to get rid of
that so that it doesn't like cause
confusion about what we're actually
looking at here so this is like the the
meat of this chart right from the
penguin data
um I have on the x-axis species on the
y-axis body mass
but I'm also going to group by the
variables along the x-axis and within
those groups I'm going to apply a
reducer to the y-axis variable
um so here the reducer is mean but I
could also change this to count or
or sub or median or
deviation and these are all like D3
methods but there's a whole bunch of
functions that you could apply to
actually do these aggregated summary
statistics by group within your charts
oh yeah somewhere in there your pot
let's say you're setting the color to
red
how do you distinguish between the color
red and a column named red
oh great question I just learned this
awesome question if there's the column
named red then it will treat it as the
variable that's what well that that's
what it will select so if you're in that
unique position where there is like a
web valid color name that matches a
variable in your data set it'll default
to the variable or the property in your
data
um so you'd want to use a hexadecimal
color code instead for red so that it
wouldn't get those confused got it
perfect great question okay and then all
right so then another one some let's see
I'm still more typing
um
for the radio you know like as I say
you're doing it by based on like a uh an
array case I choose the first one as a
default because you might not know coal
was the first one
uh oh good so just choose the first one
see
so I think what you could do is just
um there's a couple things that you
could do you could
use set
I'm just like brainstorming out loud
which is probably a bad idea for Allison
with JavaScript but whatever one thing
that comes to mind is that you could
create a new set of all of the unique
values that show up in that property
um using actually like new set as a
method and then just access the first
element of that array just do like
square bracket zero to get the first
value
um
so I think that might be one way I
wonder if you could just do like values
it's probably now that I'm thinking
about it I'm like I wonder if they have
just made my life way easier I'm gonna
check if I could do value like value
zero
that didn't work so value that also
didn't work
um but what you could do
actually maybe the easiest thing is to
just
um so here's I'll put this in chat but
like for the for the energy production
that line chart one is just like
regurgitate the map that gets each of
the different levels and then access the
first element of that just with square
bracket zero and that'll get you the
first thing from that array so there
might be a more elegant way but like
that would make sense to me and it works
oh cool that makes sense
all right cool
um all right then all right just give a
yes or no then we'll let you go
um and you make animated Maps
uh yeah so you can use scrubbers that
will automatically play that you can
pause
um so definitely look up
um there's examples of scrubbers that
you can import that will automatically
play through your different
visualizations absolutely
great awesome thank you
um yeah Joyce did finish typing but as I
saying great talk and that they love
that you introduce JavaScript to map and
arrow instead of Loops because you know
we're not into that
yeah they're nice right when I first saw
him I was like what is happening
JavaScript why are you doing this to me
and now I'm like I love map and I love
Turner operators and I love Arrow
functions
um so yeah I I now appreciate some of
the JavaScript specific things
what's that
full signs yeah
yeah operator that's another one where
I'm like you know what I've come to
appreciate you
um over these last few months yeah nice
well thank you very much let's get a
round of emoji Applause for our
wonderful speaker this time
um I really got a lot of that out of
this hope everyone else did and then
just as you wrap up if you reminders so
again the New York art conference is
July 11th through 14th
um and discount code Nyack are the our
government conference which we're
announcing tomorrow is October 18-20 the
D4 conference is August I don't have the
dates because I did not write it down
and my hack R is the code for all those
the websites are rstats.ai or d4con.io
and our next Meetup is May 9th of Jeff
Ryan and we need space for June and July
and onwards and speakers beyond that so
let us know if you want to attend the
conference let us know if you want to
host the Meetup let us know if you want
to speak at the conference of the Meetup
all right all that I think I had a
wonderful time I know I had a wonderful
time I think that was all of our
announcements thank you very much
Allison it's been a pleasure having you
here and I look forward to using all
this thank you very much thank you that
was super fun thanks everybody
I